I wanted to make sure that what I said
was said the right way and I want to
make sure that the message was across
Snoop Dogg is speaking out on his much
talked-about criticism of Gayle King gay
ok out of pocket for that we expect more
from you Gayle don't you hang out with
Oakland why y'all attacking us the
rapper had previously taken to Instagram
to put Gayle on blast after she asked
Kobe Bryant's friend Lisa Leslie about
his 2003 sexual assault allegation
respect a family and back off Snoop Dogg
later apologized to King for his
profanity film video that being said
Gayle King overreacted but Snoop is now
speaking out again in a preview of
Wednesday's episode of read tabletop and
host Jada Pinkett Smith gets right into
the drama
I felt like not only were you talking to
Gary but she talked to me I was like oh
no Snoop has now taken his power flow
away from me away from welcome away from
my mother in another clip snoop
elaborates on his decision to film the
derogatory message I wanted to make sure
that what I said was said the right way
and I wanted to make sure that the
message was across that we love Kobe and
be respectful of Vanessa those kids yes
that's what the whole intent was to
protect that woman and their babies over
there because she's still grieving yeah
and let's give them that respect
Gayle took to Instagram to apologize for
the out-of-context clip I know that if I
had only seen the clip that you saw I'd
be extremely angry with me too I am
mortified I'm embarrassed and I am very
angry
she told et in a statement I accept the
apology and understand the raw emotions
caused by this tragic loss I'm deeply
sorry that questions I asked added to
that pain
that was never my intention amidst the
backlash oprah winfrey defended her
longtime friend on The Today Show you
know I was on the phone with her this
morning I was on the phone with her last
night I was on the phone with her and
I'd be before it's this is very hard
because when you have social media and
the force of social media and
particularly people who didn't see
either interview making attacks and I
think everybody has the right to have
their opinion but to do it with such
vitriol please
hate convene this yeah
[Music]